when the Soviet Union collapsed
eventually some of Putin's Personnel
records became available in the west and
he wasn't a great KGB officer why
because he was incredibly politicized
and Incredibly independent and
Incredibly authoritarian and not really
interested in the details of being a spy
and that has played out he has always
conducted himself as being reminiscent
longing for the return of what should
have been in his mind the post-world War
II post-cold war Russia an incredibly
wounded victimized by what happened in
the 80s when the Soviet Union collapsed
we haven't dealt with that aspect of him
yet and unfortunately it is the aspect
of him that is going to drive
the conclusion of this conflict and
radic and I had a conversation last
night unless this man and those around
him can return
continue to exist and thrive in
post-ukraine war
Russia there's not going to be a
resolution if radek's idea on you know
what the end game should be and so much
depending on his personality is he the
kind of personality of whom you think
no no I mean I've met him a number of
times too and uh he is a small mind he
is uh his uh background is uh before KGB
was a little Thug in the in Leningrad
it's an essentially and so he he
believed he has a he has a very
pessimistic view of human nature he
thinks people are there to be bullied to
be bought to be blackmailed uh that's
that's his fundamental vision and that's
how he made this huge mistake because he
thought he could uh he could intimidate
Ukraine he could intimidate the West he
cannot imagine that there are people who
may not be bought who will not be
bullied and who have something to just
call an ideal that is not his his way of
operating and that's why he has made
this alliance with the oligarchs because
he knew that if it was a pure
transaction transactional Alliance it
wouldn't work so he needed to have that
kind of Russian ethno-nationalism to to
to make it work just like you know Trump
in the in the United United States if it
was just about money and billionaires
supporting him that would not be enough
so he had to make America great again he
has a so these kind of people they need
the varnish of uh of sort of plural
ideology uh to to consolidate their
power
if I could add to that to that pulling
some of these thoughts together uh I
think Mary Beth is absolutely correct
that the personalities of individuals
and their ability or not to be leaders
are critical things here so I had a
chance to meet Putin years ago back when
he was uh in my impression he's a little
guy with a big chip on his shoulder back
from St Petersburg and so uh uh he grew
up in a uh with a mindset from his
professional background of bullying
people and so that's what he's continued
and I think he made a huge
miscalculation he probably took a look
at zielinski oh this guy an actor a
comedian and this this country it isn't
even a country it's a province of Russia
we're going to take care of these guys
and he had nobody likely pushing back
you know because he has a big ego he's
been the tough guy in charge for a
decade plus and so why not he'll do it
probably his undoing but again this this
interesting mix of
long-time historical factors of
grievances of a feeling of Oppression
and then the hubris of I'm a tough guy
I'm I'm the big guy I'll take care of
this and now we have a mess so we've got
to understand this and walk it back no I
think the key is understanding it I
worry because we tend particularly in
American politics
to demonize people that we don't
understand very well he's wrong he's bad
I I think if you ask Putin he would tell
you he has a profoundly deep soul and
his soul is Mother Russia and by
discarding leaders in the world I mean
we're probably soon to have that
conversation or something like it about
she if and when she moves on on Taiwan
and uh it when you try to understand
what the decision-making is with the
Arab world well you know if perhaps a
decade ago in Israel the Arabs really
don't have the soul of the
judeo-christian ethic and therefore
there do our own Peril we do that and I
think one of the things as an
intelligence officer that you learn is
it's
it really is about understanding the
enemy and in his case his soul is deeply
Russian uh deeply embedded in this is
this Dignity of what was in the past
um and unless you Embrace that and and
deal with that aspect of them rather
than discarding and say he's a slightly
lesser human being then you can't win a
conflict
they're very different Russian Souls so
I I don't like this essential
essentialization of uh of Russia I'm not
so sure that it's about the Russian soul
I think he he he Taps into that but from
all his actions he behaves like a little
Thug he assassinates people so is that
is that the Russian soul I don't think
so I think it's it's someone who
understands the need of people to belong
to being something bigger than them that
he got it but then he does it you know
Hitler the the Germans Soul so he
understood that you need people to come
together and he did very he did very
well at the big meetings at Nuremberg
and all that does that mean that he had
a deep sense of the German Soul no these
people they used and instrumentalized uh
What uh what they see and they do it at
their level and with the level of a
small mind it's the level of a thug